[Music]
on this Tuesday night reaction to the
prime minister's plan to tackle foreign
interference what does this Repertory
even do it sounds like a fake job plus
China is warning that conflict with the
U.S may be inevitable
what the head of the European commission
thinks of Canada's support for Ukraine
the goal for zero group homes we've
doubled the number of support workers a
Canadian company's bold initiative to
keep kids with their families
plus denied an education the reality for
women and girls in Afghanistan that is
important and how Canadians are trying
to keep teaching them
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with reaction to the prime
minister's plans to probe foreign
interference in Canada's Democratic
process after weeks of saying there was
no need to launch further investigations
prime minister Justin Trudeau now says a
special rapporteur will be appointed and
both a parliamentary committee and the
National Security and intelligence
review agency will study foreign
interference the opposition though says
all of those things lack transparency
they're still demanding a public inquiry
Eric Sorensen has our top story tonight
something called a repertoire a fake new
position that they have invented
opposition leader Pierre pauliev heaped
scorn on the prime minister's decision
to appoint an eminent Canadian to
investigate Chinese and other foreign
interference in recent Canadian
elections the three main opposition
leaders all still demand an independent
and public inquiry we need an
independent and open investigation
headed by someone approved by all
parties in the House of Commons not
another liberal establishment
Ottawa Insider it has to be a person
that the population will trust we will
ensure that whoever is chosen in
Kingston today the Prime Minister said
he's open to suggestions from the
opposition not for a public inquiry but
for a repertoire that Canadians can
trust to give all Canadians confidence
in the openness transparency and rigor
of that process but critics say Trudeau
has not earned trust because for weeks
he downplayed the seriousness of
election interference still the NDP
leader did not dismiss the repertoire
out of hand but we need to see a process
that's independent and public and right
now my concerns are that with the
appointment of a special repertoire it
will qualify as independent but I still
remain concerned about the public
element of it with a repertoire plus a
security and intelligence Committee of
Parliament and the National Security and
intelligence review agency no fewer than
three bodies will look into election
interference it's a bad moment for
Canadian national security policy to end
it up in this
impasse where
um a buck is being passed not just to
one hand but to three the principle of
ministerial accountability
has been Paramount here and that the
procedure and house Affairs committee
the Liberals filibustered a conservative
motion to call the prime minister's
Chief of Staff Katie Telford to testify
on Election interference and later the
committee couldn't restart the meeting
because the Liberals didn't show up Eric
Sorensen Global News
there are fresh signs China's
relationship with the west and in
particular the United States is
deteriorating China's president accuses
the U.S of seeking containment of his
country a term loaded with Cold War era
meaning and China's new foreign minister
lashed out at the U.S today accusing the
Biden administration of being engaged in
a zero-sum game whereas he put it you
live and I die Jackson prosco reports
the tone from Beijing was unusually
terse and direct
if the United States does not hit the
brakes but continues to speed down the
wrong path said China's foreign minister
then there will surely be conflict and
confrontation his comments came after a
forceful speech by Chinese president Xi
Jinping she warned that Western
countries led by the U.S have brought
severe challenges to China's development
blaming a strategy of containment and
suppression a reference to newly
established American military bases in
the Philippines and U.S support for
Taiwan which China calls a red line and
disrespectful of its sovereignty the
president's approach to China has not
changed and again we've been very clear
we do not see conflict and do and we do
not want conflict we see this as a
consequential relationship that we will
continue to manage the White House has
long maintained its only interested in
competition with China and we will
compete and we'll be will responsibly
manage that competition so that it
doesn't Veer into conflict the last few
months have tested that strategy like
never before from the Chinese spy
balloon over the U.S to public
accusations from Washington that China
May provide military aid to Russia for
the war in Ukraine this would be a
serious problem for us in our
relationship with China the bigger
problem maybe China's interest in
surpassing the U.S as the dominant
superpower experts warn that Shirley
raises the risk of Confrontation the
United States in particular has to react
to that essentially a statement that
they will do everything in their power
to become the preeminent military and
economic power in the world by the end
of the century
um so that requires a reaction from the
West they don't want that to happen
against that reality China seems to be
signaling a shift in strategy making it
clear that like the West it's ready to
defend its own interests Jackson Roscoe
Global News Washington
prime minister Justin Trudeau is hosting
the head of the European commission who
is on a two-day visit to Canada tonight
Ursula vanderlein addressed a joint
session of Parliament and support for
Ukraine was a major theme
and we will keep supporting Ukraine for
as long as it takes
there were multiple standing ovations
during her speech a chief political
correspondent David Aiken was listening
and he joins us now David
uh Donna Ursula Wonderland is a German
politician she was elected president of
the uh European Commission in 2019 and
she is widely seen as having played a
key role in uniting Europe and keeping
Europe United in the face of Russian
aggression in Ukraine
President Putin refuses
to recognize
their freedom
and their independence
and this we can simply not accept
vanderlein was recorded the rare honor
Tuesday of addressing the Canadian
Parliament prime minister Justin Trudeau
said vonderline's leadership in the
European Union has been crucial for the
continent's security and defense you are
here as an inspirational leader who has
been Central to galvanizing support for
Ukraine and its people not only across
Europe but around the world before she
became leader of the EU vonderlein
served in the cabinet of German
Chancellor Angela Merkel including as
her minister of defense last year
vonderlein was named by Forbes Magazine
as the most powerful woman in the world
her key Mission these days is to
maintain European Unity on Russia while
seeking more aid for Ukraine we will
never accept that the military power
tanks across an international border
we will never
accept that Putin denies the very
existence of Ukraine as a state
and as a nation Trudeau said Canada is
committed to assisting we will stand
shoulder to shoulder together with our
European partners for Ukraine new
assistance announced Tuesday includes
enhancing the Canadian Army's training
mission in Poland to now include
Advanced combat medic training Canada
will also provide an additional three
million dollars
[Music]
to help Ukraine clear land mines
vonderlein said Canada's assistance to
Ukraine has not gone unnoticed in Europe
that Canada is doing much more than its
fair share already compared to others
and is going Way Beyond what is uh
necessary
now as for Ukraine and the future
defense of Europe both of these leaders
will now turn their attention towards
the next NATO summit summit of
presidents and prime ministers that's
going to be held in July not far from
Russia's borders in Lithuania Donna okay
David Aiken and Ottawa tonight thank you
reports in the U.S and Germany suggest a
pro-ukrainian group was responsible for
last September's attack on the Nordstrom
pipelines which carried natural gas from
Russia to Northern Germany underwater
explosions in the Baltic Sea damage
those pipelines and sparked an
international back and forth over who is
to blame citing Anonymous intelligence
sources the New York Times and the
German newspaper design now say a
pro-ukrainian group was likely behind it
the German newspaper says investigators
believe a team of six people carried out
the operation on a yacht rented from a
ukrainian-owned company both reports say
there is no evidence the Ukrainian
government was involved or directed The
sabotage
a precedent setting plan for child
welfare coming up one Ontario
community's goal to keep kids with their
families plus outraged what keeps
igniting huge protests in France
the word broken is often used to
describe the child welfare system in
Canada kids who are sent to foster homes
and group homes sometimes leave more
traumatized than when they arrived
tonight in the first of a two-part
series we look for Solutions both
indigenous lead and mainstream we begin
in a tiny pocket of Southern Ontario
where a Visionary and determined leader
has carved out a new way of looking
after kids and families Carolyn Jarvis
reports
the thing about having six kids under
the age of seven you're hungry is that
conducting an uninterrupted interview
she's climbing on the table it's
impossible you need some loving what do
you need oh you're so thirsty but such
is the happy chaos of the crawl family a
little crazy but doable a family that
only a few years ago might not have been
kept together
that's because the two youngest Grace
and hope are actually cousins to the
rest brought here because their mother
wasn't able to take care of them
historically Children's Aid would have
placed the girls in a foster home with
strangers everybody went to foster care
and they'd miss out on everything that
they should know like their family but
today Sarnia Lambton Children's Aid is
fighting to keep children out of care
led by a woman the crawls have never
even met
Don flagel family-based care right off
the Hop was one of the the priority
areas in 2015 Dawn created a precedent
setting plan chasing zero Sarnia Cas
wanted to reach zero kids in care we're
going to stop raising kids that
Children's Aid societies as an
institution we shouldn't be parenting
that meant no foster homes and crucially
no group homes those are communal houses
for vulnerable youth that often produce
disastrous results I fundamentally
reject the idea that there is no other
option for a young person other than
placing them in a in a group CARE kids
told Dawn how brutal group homes were
and she listened I feel like an inmate
I'd rather be in jail not treated like a
human being good morning everyone what
Don and her team did instead was take
the money that would have been spent on
expensive for-profit group homes and
move it into prevention programs and
supporting families we doubled the
number of support workers the workers
who could go into family homes and help
them with attachments security food
cards gas cards budgeting like whatever
the family might need when biological
parents weren't an option extended
family or kinship Arrangements
automatically became the next
consideration
today the number of kids in care is down
50 percent from a decade ago and Sarnia
Cas hasn't placed a single child in a
group home in four years the only
Children's Aid Society in Ontario to do
that and sustain it that truly is
spectacular I do think that the example
of a Sarnia is one that the collection
of Children's Aid societies should take
a closer look at in sarnia's Youth Court
a local judge saw the impact the number
of cases involving kids in care dropped
she said
but Sarnia Cas has become a victim of
its own success because its provincial
funding is calculated in part by how
many kids are in care it's lost over a
million dollars from its annual budget
that's not a great feeling right now
putting the very prevention work which
enabled its success at risk you can't
have a funding model that is completely
misaligned with the outcomes that you
want to see Ontario's Ministry of
children claims its funding model
provides full Financial flexibility but
Don says with fewer kids in care there's
still less money overall despite this
she is unwavering in her commitment to
do things differently
and to keep families like the crawls
together
Carolyn Jarvis Global News Sarnia
tomorrow Carolyn Jarvis takes us to the
North shore of Lake Huron where an
indigenous organization is Reviving its
culture and bringing its children home
still ahead the search for a Canadian
woman missing in Iran for over a year
[Music]
foreign
of protests in France the largest yet
over the government's plans to increase
the retirement age from 62 to 64.
demonstrators set fire to garbage can
smashed cars and blocked fuel deliveries
at French refineries today marked the
sixth day of these strikes and protests
since mid-January unions are vowing to
bring the country to a standstill with
rolling strikes unless the controversial
pension reforms are axed
a family in British Columbia is speaking
out about The Disappearance of a
Canadian woman in Iran the 35 year old
vanished after arriving in Tehran nearly
a year and a half ago her family
believed she's been detained but have no
proof they're concerned the Canadian
government isn't doing enough to help
track her down nagar moshahedi Has This
Global News exclusive
plea for help
a father desperate to find his missing
daughter
35 year old Canadian Iran from Metro
Vancouver bernus battle minion has been
missing in Iran for nearly a year and a
half her family believes she has been
detained there's no record of her arrest
or of any charges but the family says
two sources in Iran allege she's being
held on super threats to National
Security
boy
middle name
she left for Iran with her partner
Matthew Safari in November of 2021 her
parents say the couple had plans to
travel to the Persian Gulf island of
quiche they were in constant contact
with her but since Landing in Tehran
nothing Global News reached out to
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie's
office which referred the question to
officials at Global Affairs Canada they
said they are aware and are gathering
further information to provide Consular
assistance the family notified Global
Affairs of vanish's mysterious
disappearance last year in recorded
phone conversations Global Affairs
confirms they didn't act after they were
made aware she had disappeared in Iran
when a family representative asked why
they said they were waiting for a
callback that never happened a policy
the family says makes no sense when you
know a Canadian citizen has been
detained in another country and she's
been missing why you didn't call the
family and why there was no phone call
no follow-up afterwards it's getting
sensitive okay we're just take the time
to speak to the person well you have
taken your time the last message the
family received from Bay News was a text
she sent to her brother Muhammad on
November the 5th 2021 she wrote I'm not
in turkey with a photo of what her
family says is the hotel the couple
stayed at during their layover in
Istanbul vanish's boarding pass shows
her as being on Turkish Airlines flight
76 from Vancouver to Istanbul on
November the 4th Landing in Tehran on
flight 872 on November the 6th but the
in Mount clemeni airport police
Authority provided a document to the
battle Minions saying was seen at
the airport in Tehran on November the
9th it's unclear what happened between
November the 6th and 9th at the airport
I help her with the renovation standing
in the now abandoned downtown Vancouver
apartment of his sister Mohammed feels
sadness surrounded by banish's presence
all these things around here it just
reminds me of her and the fact that
after 15 months they don't tell us what
has happened
it just shows me that she hasn't done
anything
Global News
the fight for rights next how Canadians
are trying to help Afghan women and
girls keep learning
[Music]
since the West retreated from
Afghanistan and the Taliban took power
again life has slowly descended Into the
Dark Ages according to the United
Nations of the more than 28 million
Afghans now in need of humanitarian Aid
more than half are women and children
there are multiple violations of human
rights and fundamental freedoms
including Banning women from University
and girls from secondary schools turia
isri and shagofa danish explain how
Canadian Aid agencies are working to
reach them and help them
fighting cases at the courthouse in
Kabul the dream job for law students
like fatimars instead she spends her
days fighting the Taliban and at Great
personal risk I lost my everything my
work my freedom
She Was preparing for her final exam
when the edicts came down barring women
from going to University faramas is not
her real name Global News is protecting
her identity out of fear for her life
the Taliban has threatened her before
for protesting against what human rights
organizations call a gender apartheid
they said to us if you participated
again and in these programs we will tell
you that Crackdown has forced education
Advocates to change their strategy how
are you reaching these women and girls
women are accessing the program online
we also have a digital library of
learning materials and we see usage in
the tens of thousands every month
downloads from inside Afghanistan the
organization Canadian women for Afghan
women is connecting with female students
directly in their homes through online
learning but reliable internet and power
can be hard to come by that's why the
aid agency wants the Canadian government
to approve student B visas faster so
that Afghan women can continue their
education here but the organization says
many applications are being denied the
reason that they're given is that it's
suspected that they have what's called
dual intent that they're not in fact
coming for a short-term study period to
do their degree and go home but that
they want to permanently relocate the
federal government has committed to
permanently relocating 40 000 Afghan
refugees but there are concerns Canada
and the world are not moving quickly
enough we are over 500 Days since girls
in Afghanistan can go to school that is
that is abhorrent that is an abhorrent
stain on our Global Community are you
hopeful for your future currently
situations and there is no any hope and
to have a greater situation A
deteriorating situation depriving women
of the right to an education and a
future tariya isri Global News Ottawa
thank you
and tomorrow we'll tell you about the
danger women journalists in Afghanistan
face doing their jobs and the calls for
Canada to bring more of them to safety
that is global national for this Tuesday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
is a snowy shot of the bank Street
bridge over ottawa's Rideau Canal we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye foreign
[Music]